з приводу 25 лютого
Я приїхав в офіс ми тут була величезна
чага Людей просто ну Всі розуміють який
був хаос Ніхто не знав що робити як
робити де робити ми приїхали сюди тому
що знали що тут отримують зброю
величезна черга декілька сот людей 25
лютого це вже був десь обід я вистояв
чотирьох годинну чергу десь до 17:00
отримати зброю Ми сіли з хлопцями з
Молодіжки також в нас було п'ятеро людей
саме з Києва ми сіли тут на парковці Ми
почали сперечати магазини патронами
вийшов Артур Герасимов це співголова
фракції європейська Солідарність
народний депутат України він просто сів
поряд з нами З таким же автоматом і
почав ним розповідати Пацани як треба
правильно заряджати магазин як треба
правильно цілитись як треба правильно
знімати
заряджати і стріляти потім вийшов Петро
Олексійович Порошенко Ми всі тут вже
зібралися почали розбиватися по
підрозділах пов коментарях по ротах В
кого є бойовий досвід в кого нема вийшов
Петро Олексійович і ви знаєте як батько
справді як батько просто сказав хлопці
не треба перейматись ми переможемо зараз
ворог біля воріт але в будь-якому
випадку ви всі тут впевнено зібрались
задля того щоб розбити ворога і
звільнити повністю всі українські землі
ми не дамо ворогу захопити Київ тобто як
образно кажу не можу цитувати його тому
що це було б його котом але пасив був
саме такий ми вирушили вперше своє
бойове завдання на пару діб потім А ми
були в своєму одязі хто в чому прийшов
пару діб ми приїхали знову сюди просто
відпочити
взяти новий боєкомплект і вирушати знов
на бойове завдання і нам сказали що є
військова форма яку для нас роздобула
справа громад
Брати по зброї тобто Ми вже знали о в
нас щось є ми будемо далі не в своєму
тому що чесно кажучи в перший день в
мене просто порвалося все все в чому я
прийшов був впевнених штанях в порвані
курці і щоб ви розуміли я стояв у черзі
на складі отримувати форму
обмундирування
екіпіровку мені видавала Марина
Анатоліївна ще потім я пам'ятаю коли ми
приїздили сюди там відпочити
годувала нас одягала нас і ви знаєте це
все ну всі кажуть піані це було не на
камеру Я вам зараз це розповідаю як
очевидець цих подій і це було справді
від душі це було від того що людина не
залишилась в островані всі не залишились
просто це просто місце сили місце тих
людей які точно знали що не залишить
країну важкий час
асистеми подіями останні питання У
зв'язку з останніми подіями і ти сказав
що тобі хор та грубо кажучи віддав
настанови людям які прийшли сюди
і
скажи от як ти думаєш коли він сказав що
ми обов'язково переможемо чи був він
правий він 100% був правий завжди інколи
люди можуть не розуміти те що каже
проходили Олексійович тому що просто не
може цього зрозуміти Але
я впевнений в тому що він ніколи не
помиляється він тоді дивився як у воду
ми точно переможемо Ми віримо в наші
збройні сили Ми віримо у всю
волонтерську спільноту у всіх хто
допомагає Україні Українській армії
українським волонтером перемога виключно
Буде за нами
це без шансів